money
is not resources so money is not food
money is not energy money is not housing
money's not health care okay
if the government gives everyone more
money that doesn't mean there is more
food doesn't mean there is more energy
that doesn't mean there is more housing
that doesn't mean there's more Health
Care money is the asset that we use
to determine
who gets the real assets okay that's
what money is it's
it doesn't make you the society Rich to
have more money money is used to
determine who gets the real assets okay
so if the government gives you a hundred
pounds and the government gives the rich
100 grand
you will have a hundred pounds more cash
and you will get less real assets you
will get less food less energy less
housing less health care because money
is about relative
wealth